言いたかったのは この当たり前のことっていうのはいかに大事かと
当たり前のこと以外何もないんです
あるならば異常なことなんです
道路で裸で歩くことが
それは当たり前じゃないんです
それは異常なんです 他は全部当たり前なんです
例えばマジシャンはものすごい面白いトリックをする
あれって普通ではないと思うでしょ
普通ですよ その人はもう訓練して
訓練して訓練して いかに
いかに人の目を騙すのかね
だからごく当たり前にやらない限りはバレますよ
だからすーっと一人でやってやって
やってやって 訓練して
指の動きとか会話とか
それから人の前で何のことなく当たり前にやってしまうんです
だから私がマジックやろうとすると
それは異常 それでみんなに笑われちゃいます
非難されます そういうことだから
人間やってることは全部当たり前
ごく普通なこと 一郎さんがやっていることも
松井さんやっていることでも
増田がやっていること
何でもかんでも そんな大したことじゃないんです
はい これからあの ちょっとな
ちょっと普通の話になります
まず ブッダの言葉を一つ学んでみましょう
ネパレスさんいる前にネパレスさん方々
それ他人の過ちや変なところ
他人がなしたこと なさなかったことなどには構わないこと
そんなのどうでもいい
あったのはヴィローケイヤ
カタニアカターニチェ
なんでヴィローケイヤと言ったんでしょうかね
あったのはアヴェッケーヤなんですけど
自分自身を観察する なしたこととなさなかったこと
自分が何をしているか
何をやってないのかという自分のことを見なさいよ
人のことに構わない 構わない
それだけとお釈迦様もおっしゃってますよ
人間に生きる道は これ最初に紹介したのは
これから脱線して人のこと喋ります
地球を背負って それでも他人のことが気になるんですね
お釈迦様に言われたっても
やっぱり自分のことはどうでもいいんです
他人のことばっかり気になるんです
世界のことが気になるんです
他人の問題で 世界の問題で悩んだり苦しんだりするんです
精神的にダメージを受けるんですよ
それで 他人のために何かをすることもなく
自分の義務さえも忘れて生きている
普通の人間の言い方というのは
ものすごくあれで悩んでる
これで悩んでる 人のことなんですけど
世間のこと 誰かが賄賂を取ったりして大騒ぎしたりして
どこかに事件起きたらもうテレビなんか見たもんじゃないんですね
同じことを繰り返し 繰り返し
繰り返し 繰り返し 朝５時につけても
その乱世になりましたからね
それ初めて紹介するような感じで
スクープのような感じで
もう腐るほど流されて流してますけど
同じように それで11時夜12時
また同じこと だからまあ
またアナウンサーでも泣くんだ
泣く 泣いたり なんか世界が終わったような感じで
なんのことかと で まあそちらはそれで食べてるんですけどね
こんな下品なことやって
しかし 普通の人間どうですか
いつでも余計なことに頭いっぱい悩んでるでしょ
だから本当は人間にそんなに問題ないんです
隣の家のことで精神的にイカれちゃったとかね
だから背負って生きてるんです
地球を背負って生きてるんですよ
あ ヘラクレスかと そのつもりかと
余計なことに関わっている余裕は人間にありません
そんな余裕はないんです
そこでちょっと書いてあるかどうかちょっと覚えてないんですけど
この やっぱり人のことを心配するのはいいことじゃないかと
違います あの連中に限って何もやらないんです
グーグーグーグーと悪口言ってるだけ
人のことを心配する人には
そんなに悩んだりする暇がないんで
さっさとやるべきことをやって終わっちゃうんです
隣の人が突然病気になったら
はいはいと言って電話かけて救急車呼んで
もう車で待っていて あの誰か一緒に行く人はなかった
じゃあ私が行ってあげますよと言って
そのまま会社に行くんです
そういうこちらに手を挙げて
あれ この世の中どうなってるんでしょうかとかね
もう迷惑なんです 地球の問題のすべてを背負わなくても結構です
他人のことを 世界のことを心配でたまらないと言い張る善人かぶりがいるが
実際何かしているのかと調べれば何もしていない
偉そうに喋る人々は偉そうに悩んで
もう精神安定剤まで飲んでる人々っていうのは
何も人のためにやってないんですよ
ただ善人かぶりだけ どこまで我々他人のことに関わるかっていうことはね
まず自分のことを気にするべきなんですよ
お釈迦様もおっしゃった通り
要は私の行為でしょう
結果は ですから まず自分のことを気にするべきなんです
自分のことを棚に上げて生活する人は皆迷惑です
自分に関係がある 周り... 2番目
自分に関係がある周りの人々
環境のこと また間違い
次に気にする まず自分が自分のことをちゃんと自分をやるべきことをやっているかないか
それから自分に関係ある人々のことをちょっと気にしたってもいいんです
余裕があるならば 能力の範囲内で世界のことを気にしてもいいんです
能力あるかなりいる人々いるでしょうね
そういう人々はみんなに話しかけて
アイデアを出したり リーダーシップを取ったりするんですよ
もう何もできない人々はリーダーシップ取ったりするとどうなるんですか？だから余計なことをできないことする必要はないんです
例えば ものすごい人気の有名なタレントとかね
人々が あの ただみんな人気あるだけで
そういう人々にはもう体力で何かするということはできないし
だから例えばボランティアやりましょうと声かけると
そうするとさっと他の人々も入る
そういう風に 自分に能力ある範囲で頑張ればいいんです
だから 大きなスケールで活動する人々っていうのは
まあ別に ただ自分に人気あるんだから
それを使っているだけ
ま どんな感じやらね まあもういろいろやってますよ
日本に人気あるまだ男性のあのハジさんいるでしょ
何て言ったっけ？ リチャードギア
ん？ リチャードギア  忘れた
えっ？ん？うん それまあいろいろもうボランティア活動やらいろんなもう仕事をやってますよ
そこをじゃあ私もやりますって
お金はないでしょうに
だから私 私が私がやるべきことをやって
それから私に関係ある家族やら
そういう人々にも何かしてあげることだったら
それもやって もうちょこっとまた能力ある範囲で頑張ればそれで十分なんです
そこでそれででは偉大な人々はどうなっているのかと
人類の罪を償うために自分が受難を受けて死ぬ話は成り立たないんです
命の法則を発見していない人の作り話で
そういうことは 他人のために犠牲になるとか
そういう話があるんですよ
誰かさんがね 人類の罪のために償うために死んじゃった
でもみんな罪人ですけど
ああいうのはただ誰かさんが作った作り話で
まあ生命の法則を知らない無知な人々は
それでも自分が犠牲になることで実際に他人が助かるならば良いことになるんですね
まあはっきりとは言いにくいんですけど
実際自分が犠牲になって頑張ったことで
誰か誰かが助かったならば
それは悪いことというのは
例えばもう家が炎上していると
とにかく火の中に飛び込んで
もう子供やら誰か助けてあげたと
自分がかなり火傷しましたと
で それから大変でした人生
それでもやっぱり一人の命を助けたんだから
悪いことしたっていうことになりません
しかし そんなことが正しいって言っちゃうと
世の中成り立たないんですよ
だから正しい人を助けるっていうのは
自己犠牲にはなりません
スケールが違い 能力 才能を持って生まれる人の場合は
自分の当たり前の行為が偉大な結果をもたらすんですよ
もう確かに世の中で すごいことをやっている人々はいるんです
日本ですごいと思ってるベートーヴェンやモーツァルトはすごいかどうかはちょっとわかりにくいんだけど
まあ何がやったのか 人間のために
うるさい音楽を作っただけ聞いてられませんしね
でも その人々は今度は世界でみんなに聞いて聞いてもらう
もう 100年経っても聞いてもらう
すごい曲を作ってやろうではないかと
微塵も思ったことはないんです
全然 ただ単純にふさげていろいろ工夫するだけ
頭にいろいろな音が浮かぶし
そのまま書いておくんです
だからそういう人々は才能があるでしょ
才能あるんだから 当たり前のことをする
それが我々から見れば偉大な結果かもしれませんだけど
本当は当たり前のことをやっているだけ
お釈迦様にしたって同じこと
お釈迦様がものすごい偉大な才能があったし
だから別に何の苦労もなく当たり前のことをやっただけで
で すごいことを世の中に残しちゃったんです
だからお釈迦様がもうインドの国いちなりたちまち
あの時代に仏教の国にしてしまったんだから
コミュニケーションも何もない時代
今みたいな時代に生まれたらどうでしょうかね
歩いて行って 町から町へ
で 10年経つと もうヒンドゥー教でみんな知っている
またすっごい別な宗教
神を信仰する宗教あるにも関わらず
ある人がお釈迦様 お釈迦様は何か一言が言ったら
他宗教の人々もそれから自分の教えに変えるんです
あの言葉にはもう敵わないんだ
だから我々も改良しましょうと
だからヒンドゥ教にはこの業論やら輪廻転生やら
誰でも瞑想でもして もう死ぬ前に確保しなくちゃいけないんだっていう話とか
これは仏教から言ったものなんです
ヨガとかヒンドゥー教バラモン教では瞑想はないんです
まあ日本の方々は私たちあんたヨガ知ってますか？とか教えてやろうと思ってるみたいです
初めからもう仏教にあったんだけど
仏教からあの連中もパクっただけなの
それで違うところは仏教は傷害しない
ヨガは無双心傷害の傷害なんです
で ある人がお釈迦様へね
お釈迦様へどんな質問を出されたっても
もう見事に返事出すんだ
どうやってそれするんですか？お釈迦様一人でいるとずっと研究なさってますか？とか考えてるんですかね
こういう風に質問すると
こういう風に分析して返事出しますと
こういう風に質問されると
これを 4つに分けて返事出せますとかね
そういう風に全然考えてないんだ
そんなこと ただ質問すると答えるだけよ
だからそれがお釈迦様の能力
そういう風に見事に完璧にもう時代を超えても超えても真理たる教え言うこと
我々思っちゃうと一生研究したっても答えが出てこないんですよ
だからそんなことやる必要はないんです
私たちは私たちの能力の範囲で頑張ればいいんです
それでなんとなく今日私が今喋ったことは自分のことを気にしなさいって話でしょ
そうするとまた文句出てくる
これは慈悲行ではないかと
自分の利益ばっかり考えることではないのか
それって宗教か 宗教は他人に尽くすことを教えているのではないでしょうかと
なんで仏教は自分のことを心配しなさいよと言うんですかと
人のこと構わないでください
それからちょっと人のことを喋りかけになります
宗教の世界 とにかくこの宗教という世界は
宗教何であろうとも 何かえらく人のことを心配するような顔をしているんですよ
すごい迷惑なんです 人のこと放っておけないんですよ
あなた 神様を信じていますか？と帰ってくるんだからね
関係ないでしょって言いたいんですけど
だからそれが 神の教えか悪魔の教えか何でもいいんですけど
他人に強引に教えて押し付けて
束縛されることがすごい良い行為だと
思っているんです だからちょっとそこは分析した方がいいと思います
絶対的に神を信仰して感謝して
その上他人も愛して生きる話でしょ
宗教というのは 神に救ってもらうために神を信じるんですよ
何やっても自分のためじゃないんですかね
なんでそれのこのことをそう言うんですかね
自分が神にすられて天国に入れてくれると思ってやっているだけ
そのテロ行為をやっている人々も
あなた方はもう人を何人か殺してくれれば
もう特等席というようなものだ
天国にあんたがというのは特別にところがあるんだよ
それでたくさんの人を殺すことにするんです
神様が自分を褒め称えてくれることを激しく要求するから
宗教は神のために 神のベネフィットになる教えですよ
なおさら悪いんです これ
イスラム教ははっきり言うんです
この世の中は神が作ったもので
神のものである だからコーランでいうシャリアという法律でやることをやるんだよと
あんたが文句言うなよ
文句言ったら地獄に落ちるんだよ
この間はサウジアラビアで 18歳くらいの女の人が一人で何か用事があって行ったところで車に座っていたんでしょうですね
その車は男性が運転する車なんです
そうすると 10人ぐらい男たちが来て
みんなでこの女の子をレイプしたんです
それで裁判の判決は その女の人は 6ヶ月間刑務所と 60回か 20回
はっきり覚えていないんですけど
鞭で打つと女の人 レイプされた人
それはイスラム教の正しい判決だ
そこでイスラム教を愛している仏さんにも
やっぱりこれがちょっと自分の仲良しだからね
サウジアラビアの王というバカがいるんだからね
ではっきり批判してないんです
でも自分の娘にそんなことになったと思うと
いても立ってもいられないんです
それでこの宗教裁判で決めたことは
もう誰にも変えることできません
神が決めたことだそうです
しかし 国王には解放してあげることができます
それで人が一応逃がしてあげたんです
この女の人を刑務所から
それは自分が彼女を一応特別に罰を与えないことにするんですけど
私は決して宗教裁判の判決は間違っているとは思ってないんだよという言葉で
それぐらいその宗教は怖いんですよ
はっきり言えばもう野蛮でしょう
人間やることですか だから罪は結婚していない男性と一緒にいたこと
その罪が大きいんです
レイプしたことはまあそれは別に
インドネシアでもう一人アホがいたでしょうね
女の人は体隠さないことに悪口言って
なんかオープンミートという言葉を使って
肉を置いておいたら猫に食べられたら猫に文句言うなよ
その例えなぜ出したかというと
女の人が頭をずっとあの袋で黒い袋で体全部隠しておかないと
もし男に犯されたら文句言うなよ
女が悪いという話なんです
私は聞いたらそこまで下品かと
イスラムの男たちは 道徳ないんですかね
女の人はどういたっても勝手に自分が何かしてはいけないでしょう
男の過ちなら何も言わない
顔を見ただけで手を見ただけで
もうその女の人を犯すならば
精神的に怒りでいるでしょうに
男たちは それでそこは何もしないで
あなた方は全部もう黒いベールで体を隠しなさい
それは神様が決めたんだよと言うんです
だから私たちは他宗教の者だから
そうやって異常現象で見えますけど
イスラム教の人々から見れば
その理屈は通じませんから
彼ら考えるのは 神様が自分のために自分勝手に作った世界だから
人間も神様は勝手に作って
イスラム人だけ強い幸せを与えてあるし
もう何も問題ないんだから
イスラム国には だからまあ神が決めた通りにやるのは我々の仕事だよ
ということは 人のための宗教ではありませんね
神のための宗教 だったらそんなこと言う権利ないんですよ
人のために尽くすことでしょう
あれやこれやとか とにかくこのまま論理的な分析ですけど
あの心理学的に宗教分析する結果になります
だから結局は口先で何言っても心理は心理
仏教はみんなに自分のために頑張って
幸福のために頑張ってくださいって言う
神を信仰する宗教たくさんありますけど
世の中で 神のために生きてなさい
どちらもひどいから ちょっとの失敗でも神に首を切られちゃうと終わりだから
それでそんなことはないんだよとも言いにくいんですよ
神は全知全能で大変慈悲で
人は誰でも平等にと言ったら
別に神を信教しなくても信じなくても助けてくれる
だから言わないそれに
だからそこは矛盾どうしてもあります
だから人を助けする人々もかなりそこには出会いますよ
この間 誰かが文章を持ってきたんですよ
私は冊子持ってますけど
ニュースでマザーテレサさんがね
自分の心の中から神が消え去った
消えたと 声も何も聞こえませんよ
これは聞こえるわけないでいるわけじゃないんだから
だから神のためにやっているという勘違いで
ものすごくいいことをしていたんですよ
平和賞もらいましたから
しかし 彼女は安らぎがなかったんです
心に 普通の人はあれぐらいのことじゃなくて
あちらのもう 百万分の一
一千分の一やったとしても
ものすごく喜びます 私はこれぐらいやったぞと
これぐらい人助けだけだと喜ぶの
やっぱり彼女は正直にこれぐらいのこれぐらいのことをやると
神様がなんとか君 頑張れという一言ぐらい
ではなくて ここどごろあったあの神を恐れる信仰心が消えちゃったんです
跡形もなく 何やこの世界は
毎日毎日人々見ているのが死にかけている人に
これはどう頑張っても神の世界じゃないんだと
だから私はすごく悲しいんですよ
ちょっと論理的にもののことをどうとか考えたならば
ものすごく喜びを感じて
充実感を感じて 何の苦しむこともなく
自分の活動をできたのに
活動はしたんですけど
心の中でずっと悩みを抱えて
それ誰にも言えないし
だから私にも時々神父さんたちとかね
友達になって喋ったりすると
よく喋るのはもう神のことなんです
普通の人は信じますか？ですけど
そういう人々はどうすれば信じられるのかと聞くんです
信じてないんです 大体そう正直にすると
私はやっぱり安らぎ 安らぎ
安らぎを得られる方法を教えてあげます
仏教を教えませんだけど
やっぱりあなた方のこの考え方はおかしいんだと
矛盾ばっかりで そうじゃなくて
こういうこういう こういう
こういうことである そういう風に信仰を持ちなさいと
宗教がいう人助けは矛盾です
そういうわけで 結論 人助けじゃなくて
自分のために頑張りなさいというのはとんでもないやと言ったっても
とんでもないのは明らかです
利他利己は区別できないんですよ
エゴイストで自分のことだけ気にして他人を無視する場合は
自分に幸福に生きることはできなくなるんです
エゴイストで自分のことだけ
考えていると もう生きていられません
ある程度で他人のことも心配しないと
悩んでいる人を助けないと
自己嫌悪に陥るんですよ
自分が家族のことをまるっきり無関心だったら
自分でその家族にいられなくなっちゃうんです
ものすごい自己嫌悪に陥っちゃうんです
だから家族にもまあ必要な人の料理を作ってあげて
忙しい人の服の洗濯してあげて
まあそういうお互い協力し合って
弁当を忘れて学校に行ったら
自分が会社に行く途中で学校に行って弁当をあげて
で まあそういう風にお互い協力して生活すると
なんとなくすごい気分がいいんです
だから自分のため 自分ができると
もうそこは成り立たない
それだけ 悩んでる人を助ける人は充実感を感じて生きるんですよ
転がった人を転がる前にサッと手を出して転べないようにしてあげれば
その人はありがとうございますと言わなくたっても
言わなくても なんとなく自分が我ながらなかなか捨てたもんじゃないという気分になるんです
ああ よかった そういうことだから
自利と利他っていうのはもう 2つじゃないんです
この知らない人々は 2つに分けるんであって
これは一つなの いわゆる仏教の善行為
善行為は自分のためにも他人のためにもなる
だから自分と他人と区別するなよ